this is a production of cornell
university
all right thanks so much susan i really
appreciate it thanks for everybody for
joining today um super excited to kind
of be back at cornell even though it's
virtually online
so um yeah as susan said i'm going to be
talking about
this really interesting species uh
northern american wild rice or
as somebody know as xyztras
so just a little bit about
where i'm from here in minnesota i'm at
the
university of minnesota in the
department of agronomy and plant
genetics we have about 30 faculty
members we focus on a wide
array array of topics related to
agriculture
and we also have a pretty vibrant
graduate student and undergraduate
community here
one thing that's really wonderful about
the working at the university of
minnesota is we have these research and
outreach centers that are located across
the state
so
right down here is where the twin cities
is and i'm in saint paul
and then up here at the north central
research and outreach center in grand
rapids minnesota is where i have my
breeding plots
we also have
something called the forever green
initiative that some of you may have uh
be aware of it's um
a pretty great initiative
that um a lot of us faculty members are
a part of
and that's basically where we're trying
to to get green cover on our
agricultural landscapes year-round
so
we're working with perennial crops and a
lot of
cover crops to try to reduce our soil
erosion our nutrient runoff
and a lot of the subsequent
environmental problems that
that that can cause especially
as nutrients flow down the mississippi
river
and into the gulf of mexico
we also have just established a plant
breeding center here it's led by dr rex
bernardo and i just wanted to let you
guys know about this in case you're not
aware of it we have seminar series
we have
different summer courses that we have
similar to what uc davis does
some online seminar courses we do have a
bear visiting scholar so a
program so if you know of anyone please
recommend them or tell them about this
it would be great to to get somebody
here we haven't gotten one a scholar yet
but we're looking forward to to our
first visiting scholar
so
let me just uh jump into this about
northern wild rice as i mentioned uh the
species is zyzenia polustrus it goes by
a lot of different names uh so you might
see
wild rice as one word or two word in the
literature you might also see american
wild rice north american wild rice
manumin is the name for wild rice the
anishinabe or ojibwe word for wild rice
as well as sin is for
comes from the dakota indigenous
people's language
so this is an annual wind pollinated
it's a grass it's an aquatic grass
so you can see here it has this typical
grass structure
the thing that's pretty unique about
wild rice is
on this panicle we have the male florets
that are located at the bottom of the
panicle and the female florets where we
get our grain
up at the top
this species is diploid
thank goodness
and it is a part of the original tribe
in poesea
so um
this species especially here in
minnesota it has a lot of ecological
cultural and agricultural importance and
so i'm just going to go through a brief
history
for the species
so if we think about the evolution of in
the ecology of wild rice
specifically let's just start talking
about the gen the the genus
zyzenia
there's four species um here is a map of
zyzenia aquatica which which grows um
within new york and and along the east
coast
the species that i work with which is
zyzamia polustrus uh where is here and
you can see the range upwards into
canada
you can't find this is actually a
historical map you can't really find uh
zinnia polustrus here in the southern
regions anymore it likes it's a species
that really likes the cold and of course
a lot of that agricultural that's that's
present here in the midwest has also
reduced these populations
there is also another species uh zyzenia
texana that's in the san marcos river
valley in texas
um this is this is on the indeed the
species in particular is on the
endangered species list and then there's
one other species izania latifolia which
is found in china
and it's actually grown commercially
they eat the stems that have a eustolago
infection
so wild rice is
pretty important ecologically here in
the state of minnesota and within this
region you know we are in the center of
diversity i just want to point that out
it provides a lot of food and shelter
for
a range of species you know we've got
pictures here of the moose
wounds
very
very important for waterfowl
so
if we think about some of the history
cult the cultural history of wild rice
this is very important to indigenous
communities here in minnesota
um so this is an example of the
migration story of anishinaabe
specifically uh here for the fond du lac
tribe or a reservation
and so what the the the history there is
that there the creator told them to go
to where the food grows on the water so
anishinaabe migrated from the east coast
um stopping at various different points
along the finger lakes until they wound
up in minnesota
and here you can see a picture of them
in their canoes with
harvesting wild rice in this painting
today after
several treaties and see the terror
in seated territories we have
reservations here um there's probably
about 13 between the anishinabe and
dakota
communities
so these are sovereign uh
nations that would that reside within
within the state of minnesota
here's an example of how the how they
traditionally harvest the grain on the
lakes and rivers here
so they'll take a knot um these two
poles they're typically cedar
they'll use one to not to pull the grit
to pull the plant into the canoe and
then the other to knock the grain
um obviously there's there's there's
shattering here within this crane
and then
also since
settle since colonialism um a minute the
wild rice has become pretty important
here even to non-indigenous communities
it's our state brain
and also um uh important in a lot of our
our dishes here you may have heard of
chicken wild rice soup
um but this is this is sort of a a
staple here in minnesota and we have a
very healthy population of
non-indigenous harvesters of this grain
as well
so
um this grain is super nutritious it's
it's got a lot of fiber it's got a lot
of protein and
antioxidants
more so than than even brown rice and so
commercial
entities a lot of a lot of
food companies were really interested in
in starting to
put wild rice especially into their
mixes with white rice now
um
the wild rice that comes from the the
natural stands and our lakes and rivers
you can't source a consistent supply so
in some time around the 1950s
minnesota's in the north minnesota
farmers in the north of the state
started experimenting in patties
shortly thereafter
in the 1960s this is when research began
on the species and
we also identified as a shattering tree
and so we were able to put that put that
to develop a non-shattering cultivar
which really revolutionized the industry
it took off in the 1960s
california picked up production
around in the 1980s they have an ideal
environment for growing
wild cultivated wild rice
as you can imagine being outside the
center of diversity in origin they don't
have to deal with a lot of a lot of the
pests that we have here in minnesota
today it's considered a high value small
commodity crop
minnesota and california are the main
producers
and in minnesota we produce roughly
about 9 000 metric tons on 15 000 acres
so again a pretty small crop
where
we're mainly growing wild rice within
these in the northern region of the
state
so this sort of gives that history um as
well from 1950 to 2020 but something and
you can see here also we we've been
steadily releasing varieties within the
program for the cultivated wild rice
growers here in minnesota
one thing i wanted to point out was
the history of the breeders so dr
ancinelli has started the program
followed by rob stucker
remy porter
was the breeder for about
25 years he actually uh received his phd
from cornell
and then i started in 2017 late 2017 and
you can see here that there's this gap
so i didn't have any overlap with dr
porter
and also given
some of the unique characteristics of
wild rice specifically its unique seed
physiology which i'll talk about in a
lot in a little bit
um
this caused some problems and and in
many ways i felt like i was starting
this this program from scratch
so
the main goal here for us is obviously
cultivar development and if you think
about
some of the technologies that we have
available to us as plant breeders
starting at the very basic of phenotypic
recurrence selection up to genomic
selection this is where we are at
currently this is where we've been for
roughly the past 6 60 years
so we currently use phenotypic recurrent
selection
it's an open pollinated species um so
our cult excuse me
our cultivars and our populations are
heterozygous and heterogeneous
and so uh when i came into the program
my goal is to get to to um to to develop
some a molecular breeding component here
for cultivar development
so the ultimate goal is to get here to
marker assisted selection and genomic
selection for this crop because it's
open pollinated and these cultivars are
heterogeneous and heterozygous i think
genomic selection is going to be
excellent
too for in terms of cultivar development
our main focus so we're still if you can
imagine
the breeding program started in the 60s
so we have about 60
cycles of selection here
so we're really still
focusing on a lot of domestication
traits so shattering resistance is a
huge one it's probably the main thing i
work on so here's an example of the male
florets and the female florets and i
just wanted to show you this video
it is of the male florets but we know
that
shattering of the male florets is highly
correlated with with seed shatter so
this is something that we work on quite
a bit we also have a lot of late season
storms here in minnesota which
which leads to a lot of lodging so
lodging resistance is something that
we're focused on and then the main pest
that we have is is a fungal pathogen by
polaris horizon
so today um just a couple things that i
want to talk to you about about with
what i've been doing over the past three
four years
is working on trying to
navigate some of the unique life cycle
of wild rice as well as the unique seed
physiology
so just to go over really quickly what
this life cycle looks like the seed is
going to germinate under water
it's going to
it is going to germinate under water
it's going to grow underwater for about
a month and then it's going to get to
this phase caused called the floating
leaf stage
this is when this leaf is developing a
waxy cuticle so it can it can flow on
the water then eventually the plant will
go ariel
it will flower
and um
the when when the seed ripens in natural
stands it's going to shatter and it's
going to fall
it back into the water
place itself in the riverbed or not our
lake bed
over winter and and then the process
will start over again
um
i'm also going to talk about some of the
genomic the genomic resources that we've
been building as well as some of the the
initial journalism characterization that
we've been working on as well
so um just to orient you guys a little
bit more again to to what we do
this is how we grow wild rice so um
wild rice seed is recalcitrant so
basically you can't dry it down every
and it can't stand low moisture content
so
we have to prep everything uh for
planting the day of or
maximum the day before so here's us
getting our seed trays ready we will
plant on
dry land just like any other upland like
uh upland crops
and then we have to flood the patties
immediately to make sure that that seed
does not dry down we do this in patties
that have raised dikes you can kind of
see the green dikes right here um the
plants will stay
in in the water
for
about three months and then we start to
drop the water down so we can get in to
do our selections as well as to harvest
the grain and you can see here that the
ground is quite dry
um
once we make our selections and we
harvest uh here with the seed we have to
do we have to collect all of our post
harvest rates
within like
48 hours because again we can't let the
seed dry down so there's there's parts
of the year where um
we're really scrambling to do as much as
we can and uh it's definitely a
point where
where
as many people as we can get out there
is super important
so i had mentioned that wild rice is an
outcrossing crop it's specifically wind
pollinated so we are really limited
spatially
um with these paddy structures so this
is an example of a patty that's 500 feet
long by 40 feet wide
and we you know because
um
we have these spatial limitations where
we we can't just grow wild rice in any
field we have to we well historically
these populations have been uh butted up
right against one another so you can see
here is one population that's 40 by 40
feet long
we know that
we we really have we know that
pollen-mediated gene flow is a problem
we wanted to start to
characterize that more
so we have used a white recessive white
flower trait male fluoret trait so you
can see here this is the typical purple
male floret trait here's the white
flower
we also can look we've identified that
we can look at um the leaf collar
as well as calm collar so you can see
here the purple and the white
and so basically what we did was
um
we hadn't we've done a couple of these
studies uh this is one of them where we
have a all purple plot um
and then everything else all of these
other plots these are 10 by 20 feet i
apologize for the switch from metric to
um
um
to
from switching from the system different
systems but we have this purple plot and
we're evaluating um how how far
pollen travel
extends
by looking at the progeny of of these of
these white flowers
plants because this is a recessive trait
and so what you can see here is that
we've identified that the majority of
the pollen travel is happening within
the first 20 feet of of our
within our with our patties so this
isn't actually representative of maybe
what happens in the natural stands but
at least what happens within our
breeding plots
so i forgot to put a scale here i
apologize but this is about 20 percent
here this color and then as we go out
into these further
sections this is about uh
less than three percent um polymediated
gene flow that we're identifying
so we're really having problems here
within the first 20 feet
if you can imagine if we have say
population 2 right here and a 40 by 40
foot plot
and you go in 20 feet both ways
you literally have nothing to select
from so
now we know that we need to start
expanding these we've been building more
patties
and so
we're trying to to figure out ways to
get around this polymediated gene flow
um
so now i'm going to switch gears and
talk about some of the unique challenges
of the seed physiology i think this is
this is my one of my largest challenges
here within the program
so there's two main two two main types
of seed there's orthodox seeds and
there's recalcitrant and then um when
you get deep into the
to the discipline uh that some folks
want to see
this category of intermediate seed so
orthodox seed this is going to be your
wheat your oats your white rice
lots of your cereals
that are desiccation and allsync also
cold storage tolerant and so what that
means again is you can dry those seeds
down to a low seed moisture content and
you can store them long term
recalcitrant seed is desiccations
insensitive or intolerance and it
typically has no no cold tolerance
and so what this means is that long-term
storage is often not possible some
examples of this are
tropical fruit trees um including
avocados and rubber trees
there is this intermediate
class where it's partially desiccant
tolerant there's limited to no cold
tolerance wild rice does fall into this
category because it does have cold
tolerance wild rice wants to be in the
cold
um which is one reason why i love it
uh and so some other examples can be the
papaya the coffee bean
and the macadamia nut now
when we're talking about recalcitrance
this is just an example of what i mean
by
by viability versus moisture contents
in wild rice you can see at very low
moisture contents the viability of the
seed
there's there's no viability it drops
off
as you get up to higher moisture
contents um particularly above 30
percent water content in the seed you're
going to have um reach your maximum
viability of the seed
so if we look at this graph graph and we
think about the time
uh that we can spend and that a seed can
spend in storage
versus its ability to germinate i'm not
really going to talk about vigor
um every seed every species right that
we store in excitus storage is going to
eventually have a is going to have a
specific amount of time where you can
store it
and then that that viability or that
percent germination is going to drop off
drastically
because wild rice is recalcitrant um
and can't it can't survive those low
moisture contents uh another trait that
is also associated with that
is that limited storage time so we find
that for wild rice we can actually only
store the seed for about
half a year to a year and a half tops
before we start reaching this really
sharp decline in viability
so what this means for my program is i
have to do annual grow outs of all of my
germplasm which limits the amount of
germplasm that i can have within the
program
so currently how we store wild rice seed
or historically how wild rice seed has
been storage excituis
is
at one to three degrees celsius
and submerged in water
in the dark and you can see some
examples of this here
in one of our
cold storage
areas
this
can lead to a ton of microbial growth
i've done some some characterization of
the seed microbiome it's really
interesting i wish i had time to talk
about it today but um i will have a
paper coming out soon on this
this has been a lot of fun but we do
have a lot of microbial growth and we
have found that
actually the microbes don't really
affect the the viability and the
longevity of wild rice and storage
um
so one thing that that i have found
and what's fun about science is there
was a complete happy accident
um
is i i got like a 50 pound bag of seed
from a grower uh during the planting
season i think of 2018.
uh because i needed some seed and he
gave it to us i popped it in our cold
storage
and so it was stored moist but not wet
now over the winter this had been stored
on the farmers
um in the farmer's irrigation ditch
that's how they store their seed
actually from year to year they put it
in these big bags
they throw it in their irrigation ditch
so submerged in water and it experienced
those cold temperatures so
um similar to how we store it but
obviously different anyway so when i got
it
one thing i had a i had a technician
that said jenny i really want to to test
the germination of the seed
every month and see how it compares to
our storage because we were trying to
find a way to increase the longevity of
our seed storage
and um i said yeah sure so um this pink
line is what i'm calling our one phase
seed storage and this is uh typical of
what how how we have been storing seed
again that one to three degrees celsius
in the dark submerged in water and you
can see that after about a year we have
this rapid decline in viability
um
of a percent germination excuse me and
then this to what i'm calling a
two-phase storage which is basically
where it was submerged in water for
about nine months over the winter or
eight months excuse me over the winter
um and then it's just stored
moist in cold storage at one to three
degrees c
you can see that we're maintaining
viability um and this is after about two
and a half years so
for my program this has been a huge
discovery uh we're doing more studies
right now and um it seems
like we have found a way to store wild
rice seed at least for two to three
years
um which i know doesn't seem like much
but when you do annual grow outs of all
of your germplasm
the idea of maybe being able to cut that
in half
is is huge for the for our plant
breeding program
oh and there that is um
another thing about wild rice seed is
it's dormant
nope i apologize
is it's dormant um at harvest and it
takes about three to six months to
stratify and break that dormancy we
previous research has shown
that you need um
uh
to store the seed at one to three
degrees celsius submerged in water
um for for about three to six months so
you can see that we sort of used our
previous methodology in storage also
because we knew that that's what
needed to be done to break dormancy in
this in this species
here you can see an example of the seed
one thing that's really fun i haven't
been able to to
work much with this yet is this is a
tetrazzolium stain which stains
metabolically active tissue
you can actually we found that you can
bisect this wild rice seed
you can stain it and then it still will
germinate so we're trying to
pinpoint and identify
specific um parts of the seed
specifically the embryo what needs to be
stained also looking at histology to try
to understand the the relationship
between embryo development um and seed
dormancy and germination
so
this by all means is not a complete list
at all of seed dormancy but in wild rice
you know you can have or any species you
can have a physical barrier which would
be like the seed coat
you can easily get around that um
um for by scarifying the to the outside
of the seacoast so like scratching it
somehow mechanically for example
there's also an embryo barrier to see
dormancy
there's two types two main types that
i'm just going to go over as an example
you can have a dormant fully developed
embryo and the way you can get around
that and you can break that dormancy is
through a combination of hormones in the
environment
and then also
if a seed is dormant you can also have
at harvest that seed might the embryo
might be underdeveloped and it might
need that three to six months time
to actually continue to grow into a
developed embryo that can germinate um
work around probably maybe something
like selection and i just i forgot to
mention that the reason why i see
dormancy is important to us in the plant
breeding program
is if it takes three to six months to
break dormancy
we're limited currently right now to one
cycle of selection per year
um which obviously reduces the
efficiency and our ability for any type
of
faster breeding
as well as a hindrance as you can
imagine to genomic selection as well
because we want to be able to get into
the greenhouse
to genotype our plants
so we've been working for about three
years um
on
a bunch of different
types of
hormonal scarification treatments as
well as different environmental
treatments we've tried gibberellic acid
ethaphon
kinetin fusicolkin
the combination of hormonal and
scarification treatments different times
after harvest
and nothing has worked
so all of the literature when i came in
all pointed to that the that wild rice
had a fully developed embryo i haven't
been able to find any combination
of of any types of treatments that
have successfully broken that dormancy
at a high enough rate for the plant
breeding program and turned it into that
turn into viable plants so
you know sometimes science doesn't work
um the way you want it to or at least
your your your results um i've sort of
thrown in the towel right now
in terms of trying to find a way to
hormonally or or chemically break
dormancy and wild rice and we're going
back to the drawing board
and we're asking the question is while
the wild rice embryo actually fully
developed
um so some of the work i've mentioned
that we're working on histology
and some tetrazolium staining to try to
do that
another thing that we've been working on
is we never had a dormancy curve in wild
rice so we we've established one so
these are three different genotypes uh
this is weeks and storage on the x-axis
as well as percent germination on the y
and so what you can see here is uh weeks
in storage is zero time point zero this
would be like at harvest
so you can see this um that most of the
wild rice seed is dormant
right at harvest and then as we get
further into
the stratification period
um somewhere between 60 16 and 20 weeks
is when the majority of wildeberry seed
is going to completely break dormancy
we do have a natural stand in here
because i was questioning whether
breeding the threat through some sort of
indirect selection or genetic bottleneck
we had um had some problems with with
breaking dormancy we had maybe somehow
extended it it seems pretty similar
we may have extended dormancy a little
bit
so one of the things that we're doing
right now is at each one of these time
points for each of the three genotypes
we have
extracted rna from from the seeds and
ran some rna-seq to try to get it to
some of the metabolic pathways
potentially you know genes of interest
a lot of genes in c dormancy have been
well characterized especially in white
rice so we're hoping for that
another thing that i look at here on
this graph
is potentially an opportunity for
selection to reduce seed dormant the
length of seed dormancy
because if you can imagine here
um you do we do have some seed breaking
dormancy
but
we also at these later stages
aren't seeing a huge drop in viability i
know that we are seeing some here but
what that means is that the seed so
these are all individual bags and so
what that means is that
you know when you're when you're looking
at a germ percent germination here that
stays at about 70
you do have a percentage of those seeds
within that bag
that did break dormancy um here early on
but are still maintaining their
viability so i think that that there are
some good selection opportunities here
to reduce seed dormancy in wild rice
um
just some final comments on wild rice
physiology
uh we are not seed physiologists so when
i came into uh this position as a new
plant breeder
i did not realize how important seed
physiology was uh and and how it
dictates so much in wild rice breeding
uh and when yeah in the breeding process
um and so we are sort of
boots on the ground learning as we go
but but um i think we're making some
progress
this unique uh physiology
does impose these significant challenges
to the bridge to the breeding program
specifically with recalcitrants we have
to grow all of our dermplasm out every
year
and specifically with dormancy we can
only currently get one cycle of
selection per year
timing of these experiments is really
difficult for for storage testing or
storage long longevity testing it takes
years before you can get your first
meaningful data point
um and a lot can happen within those
years coolers can break down
etc and dormancy testing
uh this needs to be prepared right at
harvest which i mentioned when we're
trying to get seed collected in all
those post-harvest traits it's a really
crazy time in the program
um so this can this can be a challenge
as well so
you know i think progress is
i say slow but i've only been here for
three years so maybe i am making some
good progress i'm gonna give myself a
little pat on the back um but
you know we have identified this new
storage methodology which seems to
extend longevity uh for wild rice
accidentally and let me just mention
that
um
wild rice one of the big problems when
we think about conservation is that it's
not stored in any seed banks because of
the the limited longevity and storage
so starting to understand more of the
the this this relationship between
recalcitrance
and and storage longevity
not only helps our breeding program but
it also helps the conservation when
we're talking about mixed issue storage
of all of the genetic diversity that's
out there
and then again
[Music]
we we i think that that moving towards
selections for reducing dormancy might
be the way that we're going to have to
go
so i'm going to switch gears and start
talking about genomic resources
when i came here to the university i was
charged with starting a molecular-based
breeding program but we didn't really
have any genomic resources there had
been
one or two like two studies
two qtl mapping studies with aflps
and one with ssrs that had been
identified in white rice and then
utilized in wild rice and i've worked on
that in a couple different species and
they could that those
transferring ssrs from one species to
another
in my opinion can be really problematic
um so
the first thing i set out to do is
sequence the genome we have so we have
sequence assembled and annotated the
xenia polustrus genome this was done the
sequencing and assembly was done by
dovetail genomic genomics it's a company
out in california and then
both the genomic center and the
minnesota computing super computing
institute helps to in this project as
well
and this couldn't have been done
obviously without
this wonderful team of postdocs that i
worked with
excuse me so a little bit about the
assembly
um for those of you who like these types
of statistics
i like to focus on the n90 and the er
and the l90 uh so total length
well excuse me let me take a step back
we we did we didn't just sequence we
used we used um pac bio sequencing we
also generated both chicago and
high-rise libraries for this assembly
um and and we
use dovetails proprietary high-rise
assembly software to assemble all of
these contacts
so
when we look at n90 we're at about 39
megabases l90
at 14 scaffolds if you remember
uh wild rice is a diploid with a haploid
chromosome number of 15 so i feel pretty
good about this l90 number
here's an example
or a
figure
of the number of scaffolds we had
in total about 2100 and then here are
our 15 largest
in terms of scaffold size
that you can see here so again pretty
happy with some of the assembly that we
have of some of these larger chromosomes
or pseudomolecules busco scores so this
is going to tell us um
sort of how well we did in in our gene
space in assembling our gene space so
89.4 it could be higher but it's not too
bad i'm pretty happy with it for what
we're going to use the
the reference genome for
lai scores so this is this kind of tells
you how well your repetitive regions are
are assembled anything under 10 is
considered a draft genome assembly
so we don't really have a very good
assembly of our repetitive regions
so just a little bit about annotation
here you can see that uh so some i can
totally see how some people might have a
problem with this i named the
chromosomes no one really cares about
wild rice so i felt i could do it and
get away with it and i did
most folks probably these would be
called pseudomolecules but
um so we have our first 15 chromosomes
we also have a couple larger scaffolds
left over which is pretty common when
you have a de novo assembly
in terms of structural annotation
um the blue
uh is our repetitive regions the purple
are is our gene space so we now have an
idea of
of where the these different spaces are
located in the genome
we also used a
utilized evidence-based annotation
where we had eight different tissue
types that can be seen here um
and we ran rna-seq on them and so now we
have about 46 000 protein-coding genes
as well as we can we've identified
shared orthologs
and this is just an example of where we
looked at some disease resistance genes
um
after working in peterborough kirti's
lab i'm super interested in innate
immunity so we have some
pattern recognition uh receptors
and then and similar things like that
and you can see where they're clustering
in these genic spaces
so
this is probably my favorite part of
of the of the talk
is which is uh the comparative genomics
section so here is a macro collinearity
plot here's the 12 chromosomes of
arizocitiva on the bottom and the 15 of
zyzenia plustris on the top
and what these gray bands in between
show is just just this the the the um
the sentinel
the connection between the two species
um and so you can see large overlap or
large excuse me large inversions large
duplications
if we look at
a
micro co-linearity plot
so this is where every
this every block is a different gene you
can see that there's there's pretty good
micro co-linearity on a gene by gene
basis as well
one of the coolest things that we
identified
which might be kind of hard to see it's
easier to see in the dot plot in the
paper
is we identified a whole genome
duplication
in um saizania plus stress
this was hype this was hypothesized in
some of the the work that previously
previously been done in the zyzamia
latifolia
genome so i guess i should rather than
say we we confirmed that that a whole
genome duplication happened within
xixania that's more appropriate to say
so when we compare some genomic
statistics um we have arizotiva here
zyzenia latifolia does have a reference
genome assembly it's it's a bit more
broken up than than r so the scaffolds
are much smaller but we still were able
to compare it
and then zyzadium plush risk which is
ours
uh so the energizer sativa the genome
size is
370 to 430 megabases zyzenia latifolia
604 so you can almost see that whole
genome duplication here
and then with wild rice uh the genome is
huge so this is our assembly it's 1.2
gigabases based on flow cytometry
the size of the genome is actually 1.8
gigabases much larger than we expected
and we really questioned at the
beginning
at the beginning of this whether or not
we had another whole genome duplication
after zyzenia latafloya latifolia and
zyzenia cluster split
when we started looking at the
comparing the number of genic of genes
as well as the percent of
uh repetitive regions
one thing that you can see here is that
ariza between ariza sativa and her eyes
a lot of full insights annie a lot of
foliar excuse me
percent of repetitive regions are pretty
much the same and we have this huge jump
between zyzenia latifoli latifolian
zeissenia plustrus so our current
hypothesis is that we had a rapid
expansion of repetitive elements within
one and within the wild rice genome
after zyzenia latifolia split and in its
sizing a lot of polio inside being
split
um and it's happened within we know that
it's
okay we hypothesized that it's happened
within the last five million years so
this is
really similar to the evolutionary
history of maize
um
and so if we look at a dendrogram just
to sort of orient you a little bit more
uh here is wheat here is maize
here is um
the orica tribe okay here's orizza
sativa
here's the zyzenia
uh
genus
we had already known
that
ariza and zytzenius split from one
another about 25 to 30 million years ago
we confirmed that again with with our
work here with this genome
but one thing that was new is we
identified that that this um
split between polustrus and latifolia
probably happened between six and eight
million years ago
one thing that's really interesting and
i don't quite understand it um you know
molecular clocks aren't perfect is that
the we know the whole genome duplication
in the zyzenia genre happens we estimate
5.3 million years ago
so it seems like there's there's
something that happened when the species
split as well as the whole genome
duplication we haven't really been able
to unravel that
unravel that yet
um
and so now that we have this we have
this genome this reference genome i am
super interested in the domestication
syndrome i think it's fascinating
the
idea that you know convert
there's lots of different traits within
a wide range of agricultural species
that have this convergent evolution
where the some of the same genes have
been um
selected for
to for example reduce seed chatter
i just love this work this is sort of
something i've i've really um
uh excited to to begin working on
so we really want to use comparative
genomics to look at the domestication
syndrome
as i mentioned seed shattering is really
important in um
for developing new cultural bars and
wild rice
this is an example this is a paper um
from white rice and this shows you um
nepambare
which uh is shattering resistant so it
doesn't have
uh the the excision layer right
and so this is a near isogenic line
that shows um with the gene q8 sh1 or
sh1 excuse me um that has that obsidian
layer so this is the point between the
grain and the pedestal where you're
going to have that precision layer and
if you have that layer you're going
there the seed is going to shatter um
and so
i hope to get a good picture of like
this of cultivated wild rice we've got a
few that don't look as
nice as this um
so i i kept this in here but we can
actually
we've started to to look at the incision
layer um
through histology
we've also
identified some orthologs between
some of the major shattering resistant
genes in or
shattering associated genes in
mainly arizotiva
and we've looked at it and mapped them
into the into the wild rice genome
one thing that i'm super interested in
is because we had that whole genome
duplication how is that affecting all
right so we have
these genes that have been duplicated um
and so how is that affecting um
their past so typically
are their evolutionary history so
typically one gene will remain select
you'll
remain remain selected on and the other
genes are
are free to
to
um
change and so typically they will
um
be silenced or turned off other times
they they mutate and they develop new
um new functions um so that's something
i'm super interested in as well i'm also
really curious we're working on it right
now how is this whole genome duplication
going to affect like qtl mapping
the development of linkage maps um
positions and of snips and such
anyway i'm sorry i digress but um so we
have we've identified these genes i have
a phd student right now renis milos
who's working on
um rna isolation and rtq pcr
so she's looking at genotypes that
are more shattering resistant
in wild rice and also
genotypes that are more shattering prone
and so we're going to
analyze those gene expressions and
hopefully get to to some some genes that
we're interested in
remember i'm not quite at qtl mapping
yet we just started um developing some
linkage maps because there's there's
other work here that i wanted to do
first
um and so that gets to establishing a
genotyping platform um
sorry about that
so snip chips obviously it's the way i
would love to go but
um
um
they're possible i can i can piggyback
off of a
white rice snip chip which uh i might do
some day um it might be possible but
they're obviously costly and i don't
have a community um there's one other
wild rice breeder in the in the country
charlie brummer at uc davis and it's
kind of a side project for him
um so we went with genotyping by
sequencing some of the early and we
based our
i don't know what's going on with my
apologies we based our um
our first initial
restriction enzyme selection on early
genome size estimates or if we're about
600 megabases
so
we did this pilot study where we looked
at number of reads per sample and the
number of polymorphic markers that we
got from that
once we had the reference genome and we
did flow cytometry and learned that okay
the the
size of wild the wild race genome is
actually
much larger at 1.8 um we went back and
we did an in silico digestion of the
genome
and we found that the the this set is
was much better and you can see
when we look at 200 or 200 milli 2
million reads per sample we go from 2500
to 37 000.
so
you know this is an easy study but i
think it's just as good to highlight
sometimes when you're working with a new
species or a new technology you really
have to do your due diligence to look at
the to optimize the methodology
because this obviously at the same cost
of 2 million reads per sample
we jumped up about 35 000 snips so huge
improvement for us
and i just want to end with
some of the genetic diversity
assessments that we've been doing um
we have collected
48 samples from about 13 different lakes
distributed across northern minnesota we
have zaizania aquatica as an outgroup
this little star is the nick rock this
is where the breeding program is
these highlighted counties are where we
grow cultivated wild rice
um and if you look at this pca plot so
if you're not familiar with a pca plot
what this is is basically every dot is
an individual
and the colors correspond to different
lengths
so you can see that there is structure
we've identified some structure based on
watersheds
um
geographical locations which which
hadn't really been
been established before here's zania
aquatica
if you look at different pc principle
components
this will break apart from the natural
stands
but most importantly
here's our cultivated wild rice
germplasm
so that you can see that even just with
60 cycles of selection over the past 60
years
we have been moving um and selecting to
get wild rice
is distinct from the natural stands
we're now trying to
understand gene flow and and have some
questions about that about similarities
between these two groupings this is a
big thing because
we're growing cultivated wild rice and
we're and we're
changing some of the genome of the
species to adapt to these agricultural
climates but we're in the center of
diversity so we have to be really
careful um
you know we don't do any mutation
breeding or genome editing in my program
um there's actually a law in minnesota
where you can't develop any gm
wild rice because folks were really
worried about that about 15 years ago
you can't develop that without a
environmental impact study
but there's validity there um because
we're in this this center of origin
we don't want to disrupt um
the natural stands at all
by
called breeding and cultivating the
species and so we're i was really happy
to see this
it appears that there's limited gene
flow between the cultivated stands and
the natural stands
we've been starting to preliminary look
at ld decay this is a um out crossing
species
so ld decay is pretty rapid um it's
similar to what we're seeing in maze
we
this is a dendrogram of everything in
the
like maybe
15 different cultivars or populations
within my cultivated wild rice breeding
program i know you can't see it but if
you can see the different colors
there's no structure here
the only structure that we see is with
k2 which is a population that's been
physically isolated in a whole other
patty
that's far away from the main patio
complex for the past 30 40 years so
i think because of all the pollen travel
that we know we see with the high level
of ld or
you know the rapid decay of ld
um this is contributing to
just this mess that i have within the in
the breeding program so
trying to implement and institute some
structure within our breeding
populations reduce that pollen travel is
is definitely a main goal
um that i'm working on
and lastly and i love this um is a pca
of two different lakes uh and this is uh
towards some of the conservation goals
that i have trying to
trying to um help within the program um
so here's garfield lake
the red dots are from samples collected
in 2010
the black dots are from 2018 so you
can't you don't see a lot of diversity
or population structure change
here is another lake
the
blue dots are from samples collected
from shell lake
in 2010
and then
the green dots are from 2000 from the
same lake shell lake collected in 2018
and you can see that there's been this
rapid reduction in genetic diversity so
i'm really interested in expanding this
and looking and and asking questions as
to why
um
and so that means using maybe some
remote sensing some landscape genetics
uh land use modeling
um
and you know i can say anecdotally just
just anecdotally that garfield lake
is a lake that's been pretty closed off
and there hasn't really been any
development over the last 10 years shell
lake
has a lot of recreational activity on it
um and the surrounding areas have been
rapidly expanding so there's some
anecdotal evidence that um
you know we are harming
um and reducing the genetic diversity
and for an outcrossing species
making sure that you have a very diverse
populations is incredibly important for
their fitness
so i'm hoping to um expand this do a
little bit more research in this area
and hopefully try to
um
come up with something that might help
conservationists and in some of their
management strategies
so that's all i have
thanks so much looks like i only went
five minutes over so i'm pretty happy
about that
um
yeah this is the team collaborations
aren't really inherent in wild rice
because there's not a large group of us
working on wild rice so
um
seed physiologists landscape like you
know modeling specialists anything if if
anyone's ever ever interested in working
on wild rice or knows of someone who
will or who might be interested i think
that's fantastic and i'm always open um
and so with that i'll take any questions
this is just a
picture of our our patty complex in in
upstate minnesota
so thank you
um okay
i'll start in the chat and look at these
questions
um
is that okay
yep
okay
so
since wild rice is immensely important
to the ojibwe nation are you working
with them to provide opportunities to
native students for mentoring and plant
breeding that's a great question um
so i don't have any native students i
would love to um
you know there's definitely a stigma um
i don't think a native student would be
really
well received within their communities
if they knew that they were working on
wild rice honestly especially
cultivated wild rice there's a huge
history um between the university and
and these tribal nations
we do have um one thing that that is
super interesting is um
we do work with red lake nation they
actually grow cultivated wild rice
and so
uh that is where i see opportunities
right now to sort of
break through some of those barriers
um and and get some students
but i would love that i think that would
be absolutely wonderful and even if they
weren't working on cultivated wild rice
just to work on the natural stands and
some of those conservation aspects that
i would like to um i think that would be
great
so the next question is have you had
discussion with the indigenous community
about wild rice improvement are they
interested in wild rice improvement and
the possible impacts on their use of
wild rice
it seems like this could produce a very
interesting case study where breeding
seeks to promote equity um
so yeah kind of along those same lines
that i was mentioning
so
um one thing that's really important
right with any
community is to understand that they're
not a monolith so we do work with
red lake niche first nation which we
have a very good relationship with them
there's other
first nations
in minnesota that really don't want us
working on wild rice um
and so that's
uh
it's a challenging
space to work in as a western scientist
you know in graduate school we're not
really taught how to navigate these
um situations i will say that when i was
at cornell i took
i took a class and i don't know if it's
still there hugh gao was someone who was
one of the instructors and it was called
putting the ph back into phd
and it talked more about the philosophy
and i think that class more than
anything else that i took has helped me
sort of navigate some of these
situations so
i really want to be an advocate i want
to um
be someone who helps these communities
i have a long way to go to do that for
sure um there's hostilities and barriers
in place that have
been developing for hundreds of years
i've only been here for three or four
years so i'm certainly not going to
break through those barriers immediately
but i hope if i can through my research
um so show some
some interesting and
novel concepts about conservation that
some folks can can maybe
try to at least come to the table um and
have some conversations um and i it's
challenging but i uh totally remain uh
hopeful
um
as an open pollinated heterozygous
species how are the wild rice cults of
our identities maintained by seeds
such a good question um they're they're
not really um it's i mentioned it's sort
of like the wild wild west it feels that
way
um
there are cultivars that were released
in 2014 that even when i came here
in 2017 i didn't have they had already
been lost and so there's not a seed
industry in wild and cultivated wild
rice since it's such a small commodity
the growers actually maintain these
these seeds um these cultivars in
foundation fields on their farms um and
they have
different parameters of you know size of
the field distance to other
other um
other patties etc
so yeah and that is something that they
really want they really want to be able
to have like um molecular markers that
can identify these cultivars
are you receiving support for your
outreach efforts
in terms of your tenure at the umn um
[Music]
that's a really good question um
no
not so much um
this is you know this is a problem this
is this is an issue that
uh
as i mentioned has been hundreds
hundreds of years in the making
um
the university in general has struggled
the college that i'm in has struggled
the department that i'm in has struggled
and no one has really come up with
effective
solutions i will say that we have a new
president who's been doing fantastic
we have new tribal liaisons
and we also just
yesterday it was announced that we
are providing free tuition to
all native american students
from the tribal nations here in
minnesota
um
gets free tuition so there's been
there's a lot of things at work and at
play here in minnesota i think to try
um
to to to bring up the the the this
marginalized community uh we also are
lieutenant governor penny flanagan
our peggy
flanagan excuse me is um
is uh anishinaabe
so um
there's tensions
um there's challenging conversations but
i'm really pretty proud of what the
university has been starting to do and
what the state of minnesota is trying to
do for its native communities
we have any questions from the audience
here
okay there's one question
[Music]
is that sort of like a diversified
operation are they specialized
okay so could you hear the question no
could you remember it was about um do
growers um
also do other combining crops or just
the wild birds that can
yeah so um
wild rice is super interesting um these
guys what they'll do is they'll go into
a field that's been fallow of wild rice
specifically
for at least four years
they'll plant wild rice they're still
shattering
in any cultivar that we currently have
when they go to harvest that seed is
going to shatter and they actually use
that shattering seed
for next year's crop and they do that
for three or four years so
it's sort of this conundrum where they
want
they want seed shattering resistant
colds of ours but they also the system
they're using selects for more
shattering
but then um they'll do that for about
three for about it depends on the grower
three to five years
um and then they will
grow
it depends on the region lots of soybean
uh some wheat some spring peas
and then in the red river valley in
northwestern
minnesota potatoes we grow a ton of
potatoes here in minnesota
so yeah they have a rotational crop
i have a quick question about um
how it is for you starting up basically
from scratch was it a freeing uh
endeavor or did it actually you know
make things harder for you to have to
kind of restart a whole program yeah it
was pretty rough the first few years um
the the seed is needs to be handled in a
very delicate way
and um because of the recalcitrance and
so when i came in um all of the
germplasm excuse me
all of the germplasm
i think the germination rates were about
20
um so it took me
uh two field seasons to get the the just
to the germplasm to the point where i
could get you know 70 germination or
viability
so that really was a hindrance but
um i'm super blessed as a public plant
breeder because i have a legislative
appropriation and an annual legislative
appropriation
and it had started a few years before i
came here so i came with a pretty came
in with a pretty healthy budget
and that's why i was able to sort of hit
the ground running with a lot of the
developing a lot of the genomic
resources so
some parts were hard some parts were a
lot easier
i think we have one more question in the
audience go ahead thank you
how are you
um i was wondering you said the genome
is duplicated
and i'm wondering you said that one
gene is always conserved and the other
is free to do what it wants
is there one set genome or does one or
the other
can you tell at this point if one set of
the voice stays and the other always
takes or is it just random
yeah i'm just basing that off of
literature from other crops um
but i'm i'm so interested i mean that
that's something that we're looking at
right now is to try to evaluate um you
know we have all of these duplicated
genes
in the genome what's going on with them
we don't know yet but
it's going to be an exciting part of
research so i love this species i love
working on there's so much so many
questions
to ask and
um
you know never thought that i would find
what i did with the with the
sequencing of the genome and that's just
been another really
uh fun fun place to work
well thank you very much for your talk
it was very exciting um can we give her
one last round
thank you
[Applause]
thank you everyone it's a joy pleasure
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu